these things are massively successful
why it's all stars easy access hmm now
easy access I'm going to split this off
into two ways because it's true it's
true Ricky you want to add a new one on
Toronto about this you give me a new one
and they will connect easy access ok so
the social aspect ok good let's talk
about that more in a second before we
leave easy access our access can mean a
lot of different things right if I say
all that building is easy access right
that means different things to say
getting to that person is easy access
right so if I mean a building is easy
access I might just mean it's physically
you know this ramps ok whereas if I say
there's a person who's easy access i
might say for instance bungee who knows
what company bungee is what they're
famous for their they're famous for the
halo franchise if you don't know so
video games that kind of thing bungee is
an interesting company because it's
renowned for its all of the people all
that stuff hundreds of staff they all
sit on one open no walls no glass no
windows it's just an open floor that's
it the CEO and the lowliest code off
right they sit in the same space and so
this easy access there ok so different
kinds of access now in what way always
is there easy access to all of this
stuff what do you think yeah
so we could say it's User feeling right
it's not restrictive see access
restriction it's not restrictive like
only the experts know how to use this
stuff okay you guys are seen maybe you
seen the video of like a two or three
year old kid and they've got a like a
magazine or a book in front of them and
they're like they're trying to swipe
across and they're like mom yeah that
it's broken it's not working okay so
very very young people and even really
old people can get to use all of these
systems for use of them what else how
else could we say it's very easily easy
to access these continents okay so in a
physical way the reality is now getting
access to these is this course is your
pocket isn't it right don't even have to
go a login to your computer just pull it
out and off you go right so that means
things like technologies cheap things
like reception and no wireless I
couldn't do everywhere right so that's
what i mean by physical access is good
easy access there's a social aspect why
is it such a drawcard why it is why is
having a social aspect to something make
it successful
because people like people people like I
could suggest that people don't like
other people like you know actually when
something is with others it can be more
that's it I say it can be trouble so he
can petty like I these people I just
want to enjoy this for myself right so
why is it that it's not like that why
why does this work and encourage people
watch more videos and post up more
pictures why why is this applause
let me do your foil experiment picture
yourself as a creator I maybe you are
creating you put up stuff you publish
stuff you make stuff you put once an
effort into it and you put on you to you
publish it if I gave you two places to
publish it okay one where there was no
social aspect and one where there was
which would you pick and why you're a
creator which one you're going to pick
yeah
thank you thank you now this has given
birth to a whole term right which is
when something goes viral what does that
mean what does it mean to go viral it's
when it's when everyone knows about it
right it's when something's very very
lots of people get that a lot of people
have seen it or heard it or whatever
right and that happens when you've got
this social aspect okay does that make
sense so people could publish videos and
images and all I kind of think plenty
before any of these came along right but
now you can put these things up there
bolstered by things like Facebook and
Twitter and more like kind of thing and
people share it and other people will
share and that's the nature of all this
stuff it craves an audience does that
make sense and it craves participation
as well okay anything else
come in mr. go can I just disturb your
class from energy get some folks here at
the store right busy that's our let's
pause it for a second